all right Christopher is in Atlanta hi
Christopher your question for Rachel and
me hey Dave and Rachel thanks for taking
my call sure so I was calling I wanted
to get your take on these loan
forgiveness programs the federal
government's recently started I know my
wife and I we've both received
information and mail and calls of the
past year we have about $80,000 between
the two of us and student loan debt and
it sounded very attractive because you
know the agreements were they would I
mean almost cut your debt and half I
think it was the plan that they were
trying to work with us would have taken
hours down to like 35 40 thousand and
but what I didn't like is that you have
to stay in the agreement for like 25 30
years and yeah I was not make that makes
an identity yeah right yes so it didn't
make sense not like no you know I figure
we could just really be aggressive hey
what we borrowed and get out we would
spend more time but I think it would be
more beneficial in the long run yeah you
get free you get free and that's why
that's why mathematically it was more of
a political move that wasn't actual help
the roundel around of forgiveness that
you got now there was a round of
forgiveness before that that's still in
place that you can be on a ten year plan
and you pay the what you can pay on an
income based thing and after 10 years
they forgive it that's still too long
there's only one forgiveness set of
programs that I do tell people look at
and that is if you're in an industry or
enter in a degree field of work field
career field where you can do an under
cert in an underserved area for instance
a nurse going into the inner city or
going into rule into a rural town small
town where they're having trouble
getting services or a teacher they will
do a three or a five year forgiveness on
those up to 50,000 and that's worth it
okay that's worth looking at because
it's only three or five years it doesn't
it like in your case it wouldn't take
out everything unless you both did it
and you both had 40 each you might get
them all forgiven but but but that
that's a short enough term that you can
manage it and it's not managing your
life you know you
the thing you're describing as you've
already figured out you've already
ascertained this you're trading one kind
of slavery for another kind correct yeah
and that's what I was really expressing
to my wife we you know we really started
I've been listening to you for a while
it was about to start SVU and just
applying the principles and I said man
you know it'd be a lot easier as hard as
it might be to change our lifestyle
sacrifice and knock this thing out you
know in three to four years as opposed
to having a low payment for the rest of
our you know built life so exactly and
then you have the written what you do if
you do that three to four your thing you
have the rest of your life free you know
to do to do anything you want to do so
life is good very cool
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show if you
didn't know I actually have my own
YouTube channel so I had to do videos
twice a week on life and money so you
can click the subscribe button to
subscribe to my channel and you want to
check out our video right now check out
the video on how to make a budget